[Musik]
viele corona patienten und ein appell
intensivmediziner fordern einen harten
job down für ganz deutschland
viele tote und eine parade das militär
in myanmar feiert sich und tötet mehr
menschen als in jedem anderen tag seit
dem putsch und eine havarie viele
probleme der suez kanal ist immer noch
dicht und das hat auch folgen für
deutsche unternehmen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den 19 uhr nachrichten am samstag heute
mit sven voss für den sport auch für mir
einen schönen guten abend die dritte
corona welle rollt und die nervosität
steigt vor allem angesichts der
geplanten eröffnungen in einigen
bundesländern
der präsident der gesellschaft für
intensivmedizin war nun eindringlich vor
lockerungen und empfiehlt über ostern
hinaus alle kontakte herunter zu fahren
denn die infektionszahlen steigen seit
mittlerweile mehr als zwei wochen
deutlich an
für gestern meldet das rk ii 20 1472
neuinfektionen mediziner innen warnen
vor einem überlaufen der intensivstation
auf der anderen seite wird für immer
mehr modellprojekte gelockert auch weil
mehr getestet wird thomas konsum fasst
zusammen
kunst wie fortuna fast ein theater abend
in rostock mit publikum im saal
alle hier sind frisch negativ getestet
und dankbar von unseren gästen haben wir
gestern abend unglaublich viel positive
resonanz zurückbekommen vor allen dingen
das gefühl sie haben gefehlt und wir
haben ihnen gefehlt ein miteinander
auch beim einkaufen in rostock geht das
ja sagt die stadt diez i denn zwar lange
klar unter 50 aber sie steigt auf heute
47,8 auch weitere regionen öffnen geht
das wirklich nein sagen mediziner in
anbetracht deutlich steigender co wird
patienten auf der intensivstation halte
ich die öffnung szenarien und auch
modellprojekte im moment für
ausgesprochen unpassend wir brauchen
eigentlich genau das gegen wir müssen
jetzt einmal hart und erfahren denn so
sieht eine prognose aus zurzeit sind
etwa 3.400 patienten auf
intensivstationen bei einer inzidenz von
aktuell 125 steigt die werden mehr
betten belegt spätestens bei 5.000
belegungen kommen die intensivstationen
an ihre grenzen
schon mitte april während die grenzen
überschritten selbst wenn bei einer
instanz von 200 alles runter gefahren
würde das eine notbremse wohl kommt
kündigt der gesundheitsminister an
wenn wir die zahlen nähmen auch die
entwicklung heute brauchen wir
eigentlich noch mal 10 14 tage
mindestens richtiges runterfahren
unseres unserer kontakte unserer
mobilität hochfahren sollen die
impfungen auch mit sputnik wie aus
russland so ein vorstoß nachdem nach
wissenschaftlichen studien sputnik eine
sehr gute qualität haben soll ist es
wichtig so rasch wie möglich die
zulassung zu erreichen
die devise für alles im kampf gegen
korona offen sein
mehr öffnungen dagegen das scheint nicht
angesagt wir müssen jetzt noch ein paar
monate überbrücken bis ausreichend
menschen durch eine impfung geschützt
sind das sagen uns virologen und
theologinnen immer wieder
seit genau drei monaten wird in
deutschland geimpft mehr als 12,3
millionen dosen sind seitdem verabreicht
worden
mehr als jeder zehnte hat mindestens
schon eine impfung erhalten 4,5 prozent
haben bereits den vollen schutz
damit sind sie zumindest vor schweren
krankheitsverläufen sicher so wie
offenbar auch die ungeimpften die sich
zum zweiten mal mit cobit anstecken
sibylle bassler corona hotspot hof die
inzidenz zahl heute 381 verantwortlich
die britische virus mutante aggressiv
und hoch ansteckend offenbar auch wenn
man schon ein qubit erkrankt war
diese beobachtung macht jedenfalls der
mediziner andreas petzel in seiner
praxis als plötzlich patienten kamen mit
wieder einen positiven corona befund
zwar mit geringen symptomen aber in
einem nicht unerheblichen umfang neun
seiner patienten haben sich erneut mit
dem virus infiziert ihre zuvor erlangte
immunität war offenbar nicht dauerhaft
es gibt sehr wenige vereinzelte fälle
dass patienten die früher cupid
durchgemacht haben später sich erneut
infizieren
wer mit 19 erkrankt war sollte sich dann
trotzdem auch impfen lassen doch auch
impfen schützt nicht immer vor einer
infektion wie in diesem altenheim
es wurde immer volle impfschutz war da
und trotzdem hat sich jetzt des meeres
wie im haus verbreite 26 menschen hatten
sich trotz impfung angesteckt sie
zeigten keine bis nur schwache symptome
das belege jedoch gerade die wirksamkeit
der impfung so der infektiologe dass
diese bewohner des altenheims nicht
schwer erkrankte und genau das ist das
was die impfung verspricht dass wir
menschen vor schweren verläufen
todesfällen schützen können und das ist
die gute nachricht die die impfung lässt
das virus zwar nicht verschwinden
sie kann jedoch leben retten zwischen
300 und 600 schulstunden sind wegen
corona ausgefallen und nur teilweise
durch distanz unterricht ersetzt worden
sagt der deutsche lehrerverband er
schätzt dass mindestens 80 prozent aller
schüler und schülerinnen zusätzliche
förderung brauchen
denen will bildungsministerin
carlitscheck nun mit kostenlosen
nachhilfestunden in den kernfächern
unter die arme greifen
eine milliarde euro soll dafür
bereitgestellt werden
kinder sind in dieser dritten corona
welle besonders betroffen
in unserer app finden sie eine analyse
wie gefährlich die mutationen für kinder
sind welche symptome sie haben im
vergleich zu erwachsenen und barnes für
impfungen balles impfungen für sie geben
könnte
erschütternde zahlen kommen heute aus
myanmar mehr als 100 menschen sollen von
sicherheitskräften getötet worden sein
sagen beobachter
das ganze am tag der bewaffneten
streitkräfte mit dem das land an den
widerstand gegen die japanische
besetzung besatzung im zweiten weltkrieg
erinnert
aktuell sieht sich die hinter in myanmar
massiven protesten gegenüber die sie
immer wieder brutal wieder schlägt noch
unter
mehr us militär feiert sich selbst am
tag der bewaffneten streitkräfte jedes
jahr auch dieses jahr eine demonstration
der stärke
eine demonstration der macht die sich
griffin mit gewalt die militärs haben
das sagen aber was sie sagen verwundert
viele und verstört denn ausgerechnet der
general der die demokratische
regierungen weggeputscht hat beschwört
heute die demokratie und waren zugleich
er werde nicht dulden wenn jemand ruhe
und ordnung gefährdet der mann ist
verhasste auf den straßen myanmar es
viele bringen täglich ihre abscheu zum
ausdruck wissend dass sie das ihr leben
kosten kann auch heute wieder verletzte
und tote durch die kugeln des militärs
das regime spricht selbst vom hässlichen
sterben und warnt demonstranten müsst
mit schüssen rechnen in den kopf in den
rücken
über die nahe grenze nach indien sind
inzwischen dutzende soldaten desertiert
dieser berichtet von befehlen die er
nicht befolgen wollte die offiziere
befallen uns zu schießen auch auf frauen
schwangere kinder wer das nicht tut wird
selbst bestraft deshalb berichtet er sei
er während der nachtwache geflohen
es ist schwer diese angaben zu
überprüfen aber die welt hat inzwischen
viele zeugen gehört viele bilder gesehen
die nur schwer zu ertragen sind den
generellen scheint jedes mittel recht im
kampf um die macht im januar schon fünf
tage lang herrscht stau in suez kanal
dort hat sich eines der größten
containerschiffe der welt die elfer
gegen festgefahren und blockiert die
wichtige wasserstraße
sie verbindet das rote meer mit dem
mittelmeer und verkürzt den seeweg
zwischen asien und europa eigentlich
fahren hier täglich 52 frachtschiffe
durch an der betroffenen stelle ist der
suezkanal nur 248 meter breit
das containerschiff hat sich bei einem
sandsturm in die böschung der fahrrinne
gegraben und durch wind und strömung
quer verteilt
beladen mit 20.000 containern und einen
warenwert
von hunderten millionen euro die
auswirkungen bekommen auch deutsche
unternehmen inzwischen zu spüren
christina hansen der felgenhersteller
thomas möglichen hat doppelt pech schon
seit monaten kommen pandemie bedingt
seine lieferungen aus asien verspätet
jetzt stehen drei container mit rund
2.500 felgen auf dem havarierten
frachter weitere 13 container stehen vor
dem kanal oder sind auf dem weg dabei
ist jetzt die hauptsaison für den
reifenwechsel
wenn wir die ware jetzt tatsächlich
nicht mehr kriegen was er noch nicht
ganz klar ist dann hätte das schon große
folgen wolle dann umsätze fehlen und ja
nicht nur uns sondern auch unseren
handelspartnern die dann die ware auch
nicht an den endkunden verkaufen können
vor ort versucht jetzt auch eine
holländische spezialfirma den
containerriesen wieder flott zu kriegen
mehr als 200 tanker und
containerfrachter staunen sich
inzwischen am eingang des kanals für die
räder beginnt nun das rechnen
lohnt sich der umweg über südafrika oder
warten auf die bergung das ist eine
wette auf zeit und sie haben beide eine
große unbekannte
das ist eben die frage wie lange dauert
es noch ist das problem dort vor ort
gelöst ist und das ist wie im urlaub in
den stau geraten weil man sich vor und
die umleitung oder machen will hier bis
sich der staub höchst schon einmal
sorgte die fag für schlagzeilen
vor zwei jahren rammte das schiff beim
auslaufen aus dem hamburger hafen eine
elbfähre auch damals herrschte starker
wind
in hamburg war es so dass eben trotz
extremer ruder ausschläge das schiff
sich praktisch nicht mehr kontrollieren
ließ was eindeutig darauf zurückzuführen
ist dass das ruder nicht genug
steuerkraft erzeugt hat im suezkanal
beginnt heute abend ein neuer
bergungsversuch man hofft auf die höhere
flut bei vollmond der sanktionen gegen
china verhängt wegen pekings umgang mit
den uiguren bekommt prompt die
entsprechende antwort der eu ging das so
und jetzt auch den usa und kanada gegen
menschenrechtsexperten und einen
abgeordneten wurden einreiseverbote
verhängt
doch das ist nicht alles auch auf
westliche unternehmen die zwangsarbeit
anprangern china mehr und mehr druck aus
und freuler berichtet in pekings
hauptstadt meiden viele kunden westliche
marken
die geschäfte sind leer firmen wie
adidas und h&m erleben einen
verbraucherboykott auslöser für die wut
die vor allem der staat im netz befeuert
ist kritik der firmen an chinas
menschenrechtsverletzungen auch
prominente schauspieler und musiker
werden eingespannt kündigen ihre
werbeverträge
ich finde wir sollten die produkte nicht
mehr kaufen diese unternehmen
respektieren china nicht und sie
respektieren chinesen ich konkret geht
es um die baumwollproduktion in china
chinas propaganda zeigt glückliche flüge
aber nach der auswertung von
regierungsdokumenten gehen experten
davon aus dass zwangsarbeiter einen
großen teil der baumwolle ernten müssen
westliche mode firmen haben dies
kritisiert china bestreitet die
anschuldigungen und heizt den
verbraucherboykott an
dies sind patrioten menschen mit anstand
die nicht zulassen dass andere länder
chinas würde und interessen hemmungslos
verletzten unternehmen wie h&m nimmt
chinas propaganda ins visier
die botschaft ist klar wer china
kritisiert wird dafür wirtschaftlich
abgestraft
pekings machthaber wollen nicht nur die
kritiker im inland sondern auch im
ausland zum schweigen bringen
anfang der woche haben der westen und
china sich mit sanktionen belegt das
schlechte verhältnis bekommen nun auch
immer mehr unternehmen zu spüren
schauen wir noch einmal auf die korona
lage und zwar im osten europas dort sind
die zahlen verheerend 15 länder haben in
europa eine sieben tage in stevens über
311 davon liegen im osten besonders
dramatisch die todeszahlen sie sind bis
zu neun mal so hoch wie bei uns zum
beispiel in bulgarien
dem land geht es wie vielen seiner
nachbarn das gesundheitssystem ist
unterfinanziert viele fachkräfte
arbeiten im westen
britta hilpert war vor ort man sieht es
maria bögerl war nicht sofort an aber
die infektiologen ist 82 jahre alt sie
leitete im bulgarischen duplitzer die
qubits station
sie kamen dafür aus dem ruhestand zurück
weil es keinen anderen arzt gibt der die
station leiten könnte
junge ärzte kommen nie in so ein
provinzkrankenhaus sie wollen in die
hauptstadt oder ins ausland
bulgariens intensivstationen sind voll
ärzte und pfleger am limit in der
pandemie rächt sich dass das
medizinische personal seit dem
eu-beitritt stets gen westen geht
bulgarien hat eine der höchsten co wie
todesraten auf dem balkan rutscht die
cdu dritte quelle sei die schlimmste
sagt der gesundheitsminister
ganze familien seien krank auch viele
junge leute in kranken trotzdem meidet
die regierung strikte maßnahmen denn in
einer woche wird gewählt läden und
shoppingcenter sind geöffnet die
infektionszahlen steigen weiter auch bei
bulgarien eine der niedrigsten impfraten
europas hat es mangelt an impfstoff hier
im impfzentrum sagen sie sie impfen so
schnell sie können wenn es nur genügend
impfstoff gebe doch selbst hier spürt
man im skepsis
die soldatin giuliano war zum beispiel
erzählt in ihrer einheit hätten sich nur
die hälfte hinten lassen
die meisten von denen glauben wohl das
impfen sei eine art experiment zuerst
überlebt und wer nicht womit ich meine
es ist der einzige weg sie impfen in
bulgarien nun ohne priorität es ist ein
wettlauf mit der zeit jemanden haben mit
dem man reden kann das ist enorm wichtig
in zeiten von corona besonders aber auch
sonst die initiative herbstzeitlose im
thüringischen saalfeld sorgt dafür dass
alte menschen nicht alleine bleiben
schon sehr lange und ausschließlich
ehrenamtlich florian coaching für
annerose schütze und christa pidun sind
diese momente der lohn für ihre arbeit
menschen zu sehen die sie
zusammengebracht haben menschen wie
christine müller und elfriede meinke die
seit zwei jahren gemeinsam zeit
verbringen noch im ärmel
die zwei frauen koordinieren das projekt
herbstzeitlose mit dem seit 18 jahren
menschen vermittelt werden die die sich
einsam fühlen mit denen die zeit
schenken wollen das tun wir immer sehr
stolz darauf auch eine rückmeldung dass
da sich jemand meldet und sagt das hat
aber super gepasst da habe ich auch viel
spaß trans gefällt mir und es würde ich
gerne noch lange machen
für ihr ehrenamtliches engagement gegen
das alleinsein ist an russische ziel nun
ausgezeichnet worden
mit dem bundesverdienstkreuz
herzlichen glückwunsch die
herbstzeitlosen begleiten derzeit 150
menschen in thüringen schützt sie hofft
dass ihr projekt auch in anderen teilen
deutschlands nachahmer findet weil es
gerade in zeiten der pandemie fielen
etwas so wichtiges geben könne
einen halt solche sachen
was heute nacht kommt wollte die eu
eigentlich in diesem jahr abschaffen die
zeitumstellung doch bislang werden sich
die länder nicht einig und so beginnt
jetzt also wieder die sommerzeit um 2
uhr wird die um 2 uhr wird die uhr eine
stunde weiter gedreht auf 3 uhr
ende oktober geht es dann wieder in die
andere richtung eine stunde fehlt uns
kommende nacht also eine andere stunde
wandert gerade um den planeten die earth
hour als signal fürs energiesparen immer
um halb neun abends sollen für 60
minuten die lichter ausgehen
in sydney singapur und anderen städten
im osten war es also schon so weit und
so verschwanden viele öffentliche und
private gebäude fast komplett im dunkeln
die klimaschutzaktionen gibt es schon
seit 15 jahren
der umweltverband wwf hatte sie ins
leben gerufen
und jetzt zum sport mit der deutschen
nationalmannschaft uns wenden das dfb
team ist nach dem sieg gegen island
heute in bukarest angekommen gegner im
zweiten wm quali spiel ist morgen
rumänien nach den verletzungs und corona
bedingten absagen der letzten tage fällt
nun auch ein abwehrspieler aus niklas
süle fällt verletzungsbedingt aus ist
bereits zurück in münchen alle weiteren
spieler wurden im teamhotel drei mal
negativ auf corona getestet und traten
dann die reise wie geplant an
nach dem sieg gegen island folgt beim
stärksten gruppengegner rumänien nun
eine
ihre prüfung sie haben glaube ich auch
die letzten in den letzten vier spielen
zwölf tore erzielen also das zeigt dass
diese mannschaft viel viel offensiver
agiert als es die isländer eben gezeigt
haben und wir da auch gerade in unserer
defensive noch mal vor ganz andere
herausforderungen gestellt sind
ob die leicht angeschlagenen goretzka
und sade spielen können wird sich erst
morgen entscheiden schon heute feiert
manuel neuer seinen 35 geburtstag
glückwunsch die deutsche u21
nationalmannschaft spielt bereits heute
abend bei der em gegen die niederlande
mit einem sieg würde das team von
bundestrainer stefan kunst schon die ko
runde klar machen den auftakt gewannen
die deutschen juniorinnen mit 13 0 gegen
ungarn und bei uns heute abend um 23.30
das aktuelle sportstudio die doku die
dietmar hopp zur hassfigur der ultras
wurde
ab 20 uhr steht die spannende
dokumentation dann bereits in der zdf
mediathek start in die neue
formel-1-saison in bachrain das
qualifying gewann der niederländer max
verstappen vor weltmeister lewis
hamilton die deutschen piloten fuhren
hinterher neuling mit schumacher darf
nur 20 minuten seinen boliden ausreizen
da ist der vorletzter das feld wird
danach reduziert immerhin ist er
schneller als sein teamkollege
dessen fahrzeug liegt nach einem dreher
am streckenrand pech für sebastian
vettel im neuen dunkelgrünen ersten
martin platz 18 ebenfalls ein
vorzeitiges ende der bahrain
international circuit bietet an duellen
die die funken sprühen
max verstappen auf seinem red bull gegen
den siebenfachen weltmeister lewis
hamilton auf mercedes der geht kurz vor
toreschluss noch mal mit weichen reifen
raus und weg die bestzeit hin
nur um kurz danach von verstarb um vier
zehntel sekunden unterboten zu werden
es ist nur ein qualifying aber
vielleicht ein zeichen dass es in dieser
saison enger zugehen könnte verstappen
sorgt noch für einen schluss ein
schmackhafter geburtstagsgruß an david
coulthard zum fünfzigsten und dann
schauen wir uns noch ein gewinne an den
europäischen bahnhof des jahres der
steht nicht etwa in wien oder london
sondern in leipzig ergab eine
europäische studie besonders gefielen
den testern der gute service die vielen
geschäfte und restaurants dazu noch
beste anbindung und den charme eines
kopfbahnhofs
so sehen sieger aus aprilwetter im märz
gab es heute wie es morgen weitergeht
das weiß gleichzeit yao lifa von uns war
es das für den moment mehr gibt es bei
marietta slomka die sie heute spät
nämlich erst um viertel nach elf
erwartet wir sind auch morgen dagegen
pünktlich zur stelle um 19 uhr
danke für ihr interesse und noch einen
vergnügten samstagabend für sie es
[Musik]
guten abend meine damen und herren
erbsengroße hagelkörner gab es heute
graupelschauer und gewitter und starke
bis stürmische böen
die kaltfront hat inzwischen polen und
tschechien erreicht und so gibt es auch
heute abend noch kräftige schauer die
dahinter her kommt morgen aber sind die
schauer weg dann übernimmt ein neues
hoch nämlich das hoch nicole das kommt
ihr von frankreich heran und die letzten
schauer die sehen sie hier ganz schön
die ziehen richtung südosten ab aber
morgen nachmittag kommt schon wieder
neuer regen derzeit aber nur über
nordstadt heute nach also kann es
nochmal schauer geben das können
hagelschauer auch schneeschauer hier im
erzgebirge sein und da kann es doch noch
mal glatt seien auf den straßen bei
tiefsttemperaturen zwischen plus vier
und minus 3 grad und morgen vormittag
jetzt erst mal viel sonnenschein in
süddeutschland im norden sind die wolken
etwas dichter und an der nordsee beginnt
es bereits zu regnen nachmittags setzt
sich dieser regen dann bis ins
landesinnere ford dazu nimmt der wind
böig zu es gibt starke bis stürmische
böen an der nordsee und die temperaturen
liegen morgen am oberrhein schon bei 17
grad in den nächsten tagen wird es aber
deutlich wärmer und sehr sonnig am
mittwoch erwarten uns 13 bis 24 kraft
schönes wochenende